all right all right all right boom
welcome back
Oh to Alex got a lot of great feedback
from the last episode it should be a
little smoother for you guys now I don't
know if you can tell basically if I look
it should be less like which was
annoying another thing was that you guys
wanted me to actually move in the game I
was being a little selfish
okay I was being a little selfish
because I don't I get the motion sick
very easily
and I don't like feeling sick I'm sorry
but there's a lot more people watching
than me playing so I was supposed to
look through the AI to find a puzzle but
I just luckily got the right one anyway
it's jacksepticeye everyone look reviews
have been coming in about the game now
as well way more and they're all just
raving about the game so that makes me
very excited what's happening you guys
also told me to look around more I'm so
surprised that that's the feedback I got
cuz that's what people tell me every
game I play I don't know how much fun
you guys have it like looking around and
stuff I'm more of a kind of guy
alright fine I'll look hey what do we
got here nothing hey do I have here call
it out
oh but see this don't have any ammo oh I
like how I said I said in the last video
I was like oh I have no ammo and it
clearly says for you guys that I have 10
shots left it doesn't say it as clearly
for me I have two like where do I look
for ammo there there's my ammo
oh I don't know I do not like this I'll
try and walk more cinematically how
about this we feel immersed now whoa
sooo gay now this is cool for me too
actually
I'll say I look down way too much I
guess is my beta posture I can't help it
guys I just can't help it I appreciate
the feedback though I just I appreciate
it I break it too much thank you for
your knife I'm just kidding all right
for your knife suggestions so friendly
the game gets very scary that's all I
know that's what jack told me at least
which I'm happy about because that's
what I loved about half-life 2 that was
like the introduction for a lot of how
do I get pestis for a lot of horror
games for people
oh god I'm stuck already and it's been
two seconds hello can I pull you up yes
yes I have really bad how can they
possibly get to round this
- menthol push and hold while moving I
was the new controls that's why okay
not a needle yes I'm not an idiot
okay whoa look at this again huh yeah
this is weird you're right Alex you're
right you're so on point
now hold up I'm not looking around
properly hey hey just kidding
I'm making fun of you guys all right let
me in it's the freemen Oh suck it suck
it come on bring back your own voice
actor I don't know if I wanna love what
you've done to place love the ceiling
decorations it's nice now inna you know
[Music]
right but I mean in general they don't
stop yeah I hope look I'm actually
pretty busy looking for my father
yeah I wish everyone hold up
subtitles disappeared I don't even
realize that's weird I wish everyone was
as upfront about their brain damaged as
this guy that would make a life a lot
easier for me
yes do not go ahead I'll show you
something
I appreciate I can't stick around I it
is important I know I'm sure it is the
expense must go this way anyway I'm
going there anyway
but can I stop for a snack oh I'm so
strong
Oh delicious all right do we have
anything we can steal from this guy
because I like sailing stuff there's
nothing wrong with stealing if it's a
video game it's in that right little
pinky poopy yeah that's right little
pinky poopy
love this love love love this hello
I'm gonna walk slowly cuz that makes me
feel less sick and it probably looks
better anyway
you made the cardboard man hate cars for
men
oh you suck [ __ ] off so good like you
oh my god it's just like hat like tooth
I would help I really would but the Alyx
Vance is honestly very busy saving for
dad sit busy it's gonna be this is day
what is or will come on man it is a
matter I look thank you for everything
but I really have to go I'm sorry but I
really don't have time for riddles no
riddles combine drilled yeah I am seven
in the boat essence imagine having a an
arm for a nipple every [ __ ] I wish I
was him
me too and there there it's okay right
almost your friends I will see what I
can do
you have saved my king can I touch it
can I
[Music]
let me just touch it just touch it one
second I swear I will not let me just
fire it all right Johnny
all right let's go gamers I'm ready for
a new adventure you must go I what am I
going where am I going where am I going
I'm literally going I'm told to look
around more but there's nothing there's
just barrels hey Dora he was like father
to me get it hey yeah I'm eating all
right oh let's go down the creepy hole
yeah why not
ah I'm ready
nah no I don't like this
I like this it's a star it's okay really
you really have thanks for the help
yeah that's the thing I'm not gonna
write where it's hat now you're a my
friend come on
hey where's hat I don't care all right
let's go well it's happening with the
controls
come on buddy you're coming with me Alex
I'm gonna need you to shape up all right
we're gonna beat the game together
what's your name
smack ohh smack ohh that's a great name
Schmeichel
mister schmeckel all right I can't I
can't fit in here smack ohh smack ohh
sign yeah all right so Michael you check
if it's safe what salt okay cool oh dude
this one's our nipples and [ __ ]
what's happening no checkers on ma
he was like father to me I loved him I
loved him like son Josh denotes Michael
uh-oh
why game have to load why game have to
love ah he's gone but not forgotten I
will avenge you I will avenge you see
Michael I don't have a flashlight yet
can I does this lit up at all no all
right let's go here hello 19 year old
hot girl coming through real shoot to
you I will shoot you
you always better not do anything all
right I will shoot I wish just that I'm
already wearing a hat oh that's why I
couldn't wear smack aw come on all right
I will go to another school hey ho ho
Joby this oh yeah you can wear a gas
mask as well someone said maybe you're
relying I don't know you were probably
lying
okay here we go I feel like I put that
on it made a noise Sydney okay
you guys sit in life for once isn't that
right barrel
yeah I always wanted to do that another
hat perhaps and there's a hat sorry
sorry I know I'm taking long hair but I
got to try at least come on come on come
on go ah
come on all right working hat it is
alright alright game it hey boots you're
coming with me
what's your name Bing bong Bing bong
Bing bong oh dude you come with me
this is awesome all right we go together
hey hey listen here buddy are you
serious I shot him twice
I'm with here right being bought me Bob
all right
oh yeah I'm an idiot
ie voice bets not be up to no good
oh cool I forgot to can I only saw one
well well well what do we have here open
the wine
alright boot I mean Bing bong I'll call
you boot it's easier alright so another
puzzle I assume we get it from in there
hey I don't know why I call it a puzzle
you stay safe my man a [ __ ] yeah
I eat [ __ ] I get one there now
what they're not [ __ ]
yeah come at me come at me come at me
show me show me
yeah come on come on yeah bet you do it
do come on [ __ ]
come on yeah good say your last raid by
the football yeah yeah oh oh I'm the
main and the man Oh
oh that's what I'm talking about found
it yeah there she feels good to be a
mother and it stops whirring I'm sorry
don't - a nine year olds brick oh how
could I forget I would never forget you
Lawrence yeah of course I didn't need it
of course all right so we have stuff
happening over there okay interesting
and we also have stuff happening here
well I step aside apparently I miss that
an upgrade station and I don't want to
do that twice hi hey hey okay
something's making a noise there must be
something here Oh again huh oh hey hey
are you gonna you gonna do something to
me
all right cool found it
let's check this out for the meme in in
the original half-life it's a fly - I
mean there was always a ton of extra
like hidden stunned but they always
marked it with a half-life symbol so you
would always know if there is one nearby
I assumed they would do the same thing
in this game I just don't know that
looks like a weird guy I have one shot
left I don't know if I should just like
reload before or if I should conserve
that one shine I have a lot of health so
I'll confirm the shot where oh there I
see it that zombie has a shotgun if only
we can like pin there alright alright
butyou check if it's safe is it safe
well no is it safe
I'm sure it's safe I'll be right there
all right so we're just gonna pull this
I assume that's gonna alert zombies
where would they come from
realistically come on put it back in
I'll take this come on dude shove it in
the hole Alex you should know how to do
this
here we go thank you
oh my god I swear to god you're pissing
me out tickle tickle
[Music]
come on give it to it let go all right
it's a puzzle isn't it
oh my god are you serious
I can't yeah all right I did it that was
a little annoying
that's not what I want open shotgun
shells
how do I put it in
I have to do it read as well that's cool
that's cool
all right come at me bro I got boot no I
got boot
oh sorry I got strike on the deck yeah
okay boat you did great
could have gone better
yes all right boot you saved my life
thank you boys we're out all right hey
you made a booty thank you you're the
best I love you there has to be
something here right maybe in the barrel
come on boat
no that's our hey you command it back
look at that you're the best I love you
so much
dude when we get out of here you say
something you say something we can go
there or we can go here I assume there's
nothing here kind of don't want to waste
shotgun on these little fritters get a
boot I did not mean to do that
nailed it I know I'm the best player
ever sitting way to go
babe come on come on boo mr. boot
nothing here really come on man a little
disorienting that's fine oh it moves
based on where my hand is so if I put it
this way it goes that way oh I see oh I
get it it's like oh my god how do I not
know this
all right looks like I missed out on the
party that's fine no one invited me
that's fine I don't I don't even care I
don't even care
one little bit about that doesn't bother
me at all doesn't bother me at all not
mad not mad at all
let's making that sound are you making
that sound oh alright here we go that's
what I thought
come at me go ah nice shots Felix you're
getting better I know everyone say I'm
so bad at games look at that look at
that yeah hey quiet quiet all right all
right all right you trying to run from
me [ __ ]
hey excuse me
just one second excuse me one second all
right where was I
[ __ ] I gotta heal
oh yeah did he hear me I think it did
oh I see so that's how use it okay now I
know if you don't know now you know if
you don't know now you know hey yo I
could really use some ammo it's almost
like I need to look around more or
something I don't hurt me gamers I said
don't
I said don't Jesus oh she forgot about
you know boots on
he's stuck oh but oh my god this is the
worst day of my life
can I pull this down oh it's just a play
great nice I keep thinking I put it in
and we write gamers you know I'm talking
well I'm ski excuse me I'm wearing this
for my face
God when he gets so close to me I can't
do it yeah
ain't nobody alright so I assume we have
to go up that ladder but I want to check
out here yeah okay don't do that
I hate those packaging things whenever
my take - I guess like punim promo stuff
because she she's like in the old beauty
vlogger sphere and they send her so much
stuff and they always package them I
thought that would be cool but I guess
not what they're not cool not cool it
what three shots kill I thought it was
the thing I thought three oh I hit the
[ __ ] aah I'm getting so annoyed
alright let's go back and check the
thing I hit the trigger with the fire
hitting the everything I said about
getting better is getting worse it's
getting worse gamers
oh that worked all right where was it it
wasn't here both I love you like a child
so there's many places to go here all
right so I haven't done this yet okay
that's pretty nice that's pretty nice I
understand why I'm supposed to do that
dude there's so many places to go now
anyway I'm just trying to find a moans
no that's all right that's what I
thought that's what I thought it seems
like they're making this more oh nice
thank you all right it does pay off
looking around I understand now what
carry mush okay okay okay okay
they still have my hat on then I will
take your sir yeah I looking fancy
feeling good I don't know if you guys
see it but I see like the very tip
sticking out that's why I laugh so much
when I first put it on in the last
episode can I just jump down for me okay
I can I'm not interested in walking down
oh you can open these I didn't know that
finally a pack of smokes
Hey sit the [ __ ] down [ __ ] you okay
sorry Russell time what the hell okay so
I move it where there I like to move it
move it oh my god I'm too short I'm
hitting the table
should they all connect is that the
issue
oh I see
there we go
brain so large got a six-pack yeah give
me that wait you wanted me to put my gun
there oh okay this is the upgrade
station all right
so reflex sight adds display that
highlights tactical targets or burst
fire as a toggle between three shot
person single fire that seems pretty
good I will definitely buy that this one
please bing bang boom that's what girls
do right I just imagine oh it's smoking
oh I like that I like that no give me
back okay oh we got some help
nice we need that we need the what was
his name Wendy I forgot his name yeah it
was definitely Wendy wasn't it what did
it mean it there has to be something
about these I swear in their hats
well now I definitely want to find more
wrestling if I can make my gun cooler
right Oh found you
hello oh oh I can climb stuff dude oh
there you are yeah come here oh my god
it's you I love you
we're going together don't worry I will
never hurt you
never hurt you you are safe with me okay
you understand
nothing's gonna happen to you nothing I
put you in safe spot see no oh my god I
thought I swear I'm swear I'm in this
sense I swear
okay so infestation control what does
that mean
that's why was for boot boot I will come
back I swear
can I break this from the hand that'd be
cool
ah worst game ever immersion ruined any
time you play testing this game next
time mouth sorry let me adjust about my
mic hopefully it doesn't thanks for
nothing be alright so we've been here
I have my coke
got my bleach I'm ready to do this whoa
all right what do we got oh she says
protect me bleach protect me mother
[ __ ] would bleed Oh God don't just
bleach Kabul each cup bleach oh god oh
god oh god stop it stop it stop it right
now
stop it you dumbass bit Oh God you've
done that mother can you die please my
god bleach you're useless
goddamn thought I could do some sort of
decoy all right I walk through doesn't
work all right
hustle time I think yes it's not right
bleach briefs on please son
all right all right
that was it all right I have a feeling
it's not it yeah [ __ ] brain is very
large um brain is very large um my brain
is big yeah it's very large uh-huh
brain it's very large brain is very
lunch
my brain is big it's very large give me
my hand give me my hand give me my hand
and I go I pull up oh god I pull out the
headphones all right excuse me excuse me
sit down no one asked
no one is Oh God
[Music]
excuse me I need to pause excuse me
pause please pull that the headphones
alright that's the thing about VR I
don't know what I'm recording so sorry
about that you've probably seen 20
minutes of me here with a freak with no
camera I don't think it matters I did it
again this is the problem we'd be here
right here too many cables ok well
that's awkward
you've been missing out on my epic face
cam actions that's what happens when I
don't know I'm recording oh well all
right we got some ammo and some help and
I drop that
oh yeah you put these here how many
animals I'm out of shells okay
I don't like the idea of jumping down
here this is kind of spooky but and it
smell like
foofie foofie I eat your I eat you all
alright a little spooky oh don't mind if
I do sir it's neat what only two how
poor are you huh how poor are you huh
how poor are you yeah
oh you got a flashlight nice so tiny
attach flinch like to gravity gun hold
up
oh my god
yeah
thank you so much re freakin gotto [ __ ]
all right let's excuse me I shot him
this poisonous one I hate those God they
were annoying oh no oh no they don't
like the light at least in the original
game commander are you kidding me
all right you really got to get close
range with them all right we got some
stuff happening here pick it up I feel
it vibrate as soon as I touch put it
over my shoulder but it doesn't register
all right well this is useless okay we
got some ammo I wanna make sure I don't
miss any because clearly I need it with
my 100% accuracy that I have in this
gameplay yeah can you just talk about
what they do to entertain
I'm feeling more of the black ones I
mean that more of the
[Music]
that's so cool
making sure I look everywhere
ha look at that what we found no he was
like father and mother at the same time
I loved him like my son can I break this
with this yeah yeah what do you do if
you don't have em oh you just screwed
ah come on me see here but its energy
source coming from found you all right
we should probably be ready while we
enter here bleach I'm back that way
bleach my number one friend in the whole
world it's amazing I waited so long to
be your friend Oh bleach I love you
Thanks key
daisuki this all right Oh bleach bleach
decreed don't man [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm from Sweden
ha you mess with me you mess with the
wrong person
come here bleach you know with us you
don't [ __ ] with us you want some huh
drink [ __ ] swallow real good
[ __ ] Hey
bleach go dude you're you know awesome
dude
go bleach all right [ __ ] headphones I
pull I pulled out the [ __ ] headphones
I'm gonna see I pause sorry it's cuz I
paused ok we're fine
where's my main my main not you my man
you're my man under man
yeah you are you're good we're killing
it right team man one thing you need to
know by me nice I'm loyal I'm loyal to
the people that help me all right I
never leave anyone behind ever you
understand that
actor really you're not yeah I love you
I [ __ ] love you man you're my main
[ __ ] now you know how rare that is do
you know how rare you are do you know
how special this is are we gonna get me
no we're not gonna get married you [ __ ]
I'm married already [ __ ] sorry
here you get bucket of shame for what
for your crimes bucket of shame yeah
bucket of shame huh bucket of shame you
sit there and think about what you've
done
wait I walked here already
god damnit why didn't you tell me you're
the bucket of shame I'm the bucket of
shame I thought for sure I thought for
sure listen there door here that we
couldn't enter before it was it here no
that's where we got the flashlight and
then there was one hallway that was
really dark and she was like and I was
like [ __ ] another bleach alright check
if it's safe
it's safe here it is okay fine what was
life like before the combine check
you're safe right
so make a club sandwich you need to stop
bread not from a bread line across the
street tomatoes fresh then you add bacon
that's from an animal we used to call
the pic toast the bread and I'm not done
then you add a second sandwich on top of
the first one you put ham and it's also
from a pic and turkey from an animal we
used to call the turkey and for tomato
more lettuce and a bunch of other things
I'm forgetting it was six inches tall
and weighed a pound and have a dumpling
ingredients from five different
continents
it was the most impossible food item you
could imagine in any age yeah Wow
I know right all right beliefs on that
is sorry thanks Bess you're welcome
Khorasan oh I believe I need you back
bleach what the hell just happened
bleach did you do that goddamn respect
to your brother oh if you feed them they
explode is that what happen here eat
this you'll feel better I swear yeah
that's awesome
I need this but I need this first oh my
god oh my god we're doing this oh my god
oh my god alright alright fine fine
I will never hurt you like I heard - my
what's your name Jerry the little Mary
Jerry don't worry you are in safe hands
now I will never ever hurt Jerry littles
Mary C you're safe here
it's a good place to be alright here we
know Jerry was like a mother to me well
I feel better at least thank you alright
we're gonna have to go back now cuz
someone's a little Bing bong in the ding
dong and then oh you came back to save
me no I did not shut up all right you
talked listen up I'm only doing this I
only came back because I need it all
nice no no give me back I need that I
need that give me back spit it out see
you no no no one wants you literally no
one wants you
that's how useless you are understand
you're completely useless you're
worthless you're trash you're nothing
but trash you will always be trash
look there's literally other people like
you I'm still money in the Hat so we're
good but but I think I need to go here
that is not what I wanted to do excuse
me can I not you [ __ ] alright jump
there we go ah okay I'm not sure if I
miss any gameplay but my camera wasn't
recording its it got an error it's not
great but I'm here with bleach and we're
ready to do this cuz you're my Beach
isn't that right you're my number one
Beach all right check if it's safe then
as I say that is not safe
you ballbusting son of a ballbuster Oh
nice nice oh god no bleach did you make
it oh no he's dead
oh god how am I gonna keep playing with
that Beach
oh I'm strong dude look at that hey hey
look at this
missed a lot of stuff hello you made it
oh I was so worried shut up shut up stop
crying shut up [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right don't make me use this cuz I
will what I say huh come on
that's what I'm talking about
nice nice nice nice
they're chefs I just want you to behave
okay I just want you to I just want to
be a good girl and then maybe maybe then
we can't get married all right no
dumbass all right let's keep going
all right here oh I better keep her she
better not snitch on me she better not
she better not I will hurt her I will I
don't care if this is recording we right
huh well I know you couldn't run from me
huh you love me don't you know me don't
you what a trash huh well lives here
trash but you live here wish we had
something to clean up this place with
you mean me shut up
whoa frisbee
it's about as useless as you are is he
dead yeah he's dead he's definitely dead
all right hope che keep safe is it safe
me okay I come
Oh No who's that I would say it's wrong
with you Josh my love you're back [ __ ]
you
you're the best miss you so much okay so
right now what it's like to live on
earth honest Caleb
shut up I say gratitude what would you
rate it before the oh okay what are we
going I remember oh yeah that ranek
would be nice
nice we did it boots thanks to you I
pulled through good man I Love You Man
one day we're gonna go to Rome together
somewhere somewhere nice I'll put you
there ok ok look at that
thanks to your boots you're the best the
help so yeah these mean Oh tempting but
no ah come on
yes it's you what's your name
bill
Oh bill you must be so scared what's
that you want to find your mom of course
of course yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
find your mom really soon actually I
think I just met your mom yeah yeah
she's just outside
just outside what's that you're scared
of dying that's fine
don't fire bill you're in safe hands I
spoke to your mom and she was so worried
about you bill yes yes and she's gonna
cook you your favorite meal rotten eggs
yes yes I know you're excited she's
right there
right there just a moment now now bon
voyage [ __ ] see you help me boot
boot gang boot gang no one missed with
the boot gang
yeah yeah sorry that was a waste of memo
oh my god like it's like it's easier
when you're further away hat son you
know it's a power game if you can put on
hats book games
all right boot game come on come on boot
game yeah that's right you want some of
this you want some of that group gang
this simple gangbang oh yeah look at
that another one yeah
look gang look gang so strong game boat
can lick my boat dang don't give a [ __ ]
about making give a [ __ ] about you gang
I take this and throw it to them damn
you Ganga set you straight on savage
boot gang book game book gang book game
book damn boot boot camp book can't hit
[ __ ] okay oh yeah I will not waste any
more I'm sorry it's just fun Oh find you
barrel huh what you had what happened
over there huh
does yeah nailed it nice dude that was a
fast reload that was a fast reload and
you know it boot gang boot can I don't
give up buck dang buck dang buck dang
buck gang
no all this bad go boot Jesus
sorry I wasted some my mother one more
what the hell
well that was embarrassing Jesus
I barely took any damage dude you killed
it Burt
that was awesome well done sue going on
my toys right scrap this nice dude all
right we made it out of the sewer isn't
that great huh yeah nice all right let's
check this place out
hey man kiss it
all right remove my hat hat it's the
only thing I almost love as much as your
boot you're my friend man
my friend kiss it and friends never
leave each other's side no matter what
you know what I mean
kiss it
huh you know what that means it means
one of those well spotted boot you did
it ooh dude you are killing it boot all
right that's okay that's okay not your
fault not your fault at all
all right as we heal then because I can
only fit to boot gang boat game boat
gang boat gang boat well gang well okay
well gang oh Jesus
calm down boat gang
come at me bro paper wiggle wiggle
wiggle
okay oh yeah [ __ ] up sorry lucky number
three a alright bootcamp boot camp okay
bootcamp bootcamp ooh kombucha gang
alright gamers I'm gonna end that
episode there if you enjoyed watching
please please support the series by
smashing like I really really appreciate
it and I'll see you guys tomorrow thank